be sure to check out my second channel
called Rob explains there you can check
out videos where I explain things
outside of comic books
what's going on guys this is rob and
welcome back to top 5 Tuesday a weekly
series where we count down the top 5
characters teams and concepts from
across the comic book industry and this
week we're counting down the top 5
alternate realities that have ever
existed in Marvel Comics number 5 old
man Logan the centred on Wolverine this
reality designated Earth 870,000 128
came into existence when the villains of
the planet Earth combine their forces to
kill off all of the superheroes
resulting in the United States being
conquered and split up into massive
sections belonging to various villains
the story tells us that Wolverine was
tricked into killing all of his fellow
x-men when an illusion was cast by the
villain Mysterio leading Wolverine to
believe the x-men's most prominent
villains were invading the x-men mansion
but when the illusion was removed
Wolverine realized that he had killed
his entire team taking a vow of
non-violence Wolverine works on his farm
tried to make money to pay his rent to
the family of the Incredible Hulk
joining Hawkeye on a mission in exchange
for a large sum of money their efforts
lead them to the supposed underground
movement which is revealed to be a ruse
by the Red Skull with the Red Skull
killing Hawkeye but being killed and
returned by Wolverine Logan returns home
when the mission is over only to
discover that the Hulk family had killed
his wife and kids out of boredom popping
his claws for the first time in the
story Wolverine responds by slaughtering
the entire Hulk family number for
bishops reality a synod on Lucas Bishop
this reality designated Earth 1191 came
into existence when Hope Summers that
first meetin born following the House of
M event and the D powering of Venus by
the Scarlet Witch went on to Massacre 1
million humans initiating a timeline
similar to the Days of Future past in
this reality all mutants are branded
with an M on their face and forced into
internment camps whether either
experimented on or outright executed
however this timeline differs from the
Days of Future past and that at some
point around the time the Bishop was 12
years old
Cyclops and his daughter Ruby led a
combination of humans and mutants in a
rebellion against the US government
toppling the signal program and freeing
all captured mutants a truce was struck
with humans
allowing mutants to police themselves in
the form of a group called the Xavier
security enforcers number three the
cancerverse are centered on all of
Marvel superheroes forth earthbound and
beyond this reality designated earth
came into existence when Captain Marvel
of the Kree unlike his mainstream
continuity counterpart did not die of
cancer combining the powers of all of
this reality superheroes the entity
death was completely destroyed as a
result the many angled ones demons that
exist between dimensions seize control
of this reality with everything in the
universe unable to die life grew to fill
the universe to the brim and all things
were corrupted by the many angled ones
themselves however when a war broke out
between Black Bolt aviod humans and
Vulcan of the Shiar Empire a riff was
open between the cancerverse and the
main Marvel Universe allowing the
occupant of the cancerverse
to enter the mainstream continuity in an
effort to expand their sphere of
influence while Thanos was able to
introduce death to the cancerverse by
attending to sacrifice his own life
death presence did not end the
cancerverse entirely and instead
following death returning to the main
Marvel Universe allowed the many angled
ones to continue corrupting life within
this universe number 2 the crooked world
as part of Marvel's venture into the
United Kingdom by providing heroes and
teams for the UK audience this story
centered on the efforts of Brian
Braddock a British superhero using a
combination of magic and energy
designated earth 2:38 this reality was
the home of the original Mad Jim
Jasper's a mutant with the ability to
work reality on a cosmic scale a seeking
to eliminate all heroes aside from
himself
Jim Jasper's was successfully elected to
the position of prime minister where he
passed legislation outlawing superheroes
following this Jim Jasper's created the
fury of being capable of adapting to the
powers of any hero and encounters but
programmed to never attack Jim Jasper's
himself when Captain Britain arrives in
this reality his encounter with Jim
Jasper's a short-lived as the battle
between the two demonstrates how
outmatched Captain Britain is against
such power
simultaneously the dimensional
development Court a committee designed
to ensure that the evil
of universes is maintained realized at
earth 2:38 had no superpower people a
failing to realize that Jim Jasper's had
killed them all the dimensional
development court initiated an event
called the big push
which would introduce superpowers to the
realities population in response Jim
Jasper's initiated the Jaspers warp the
name given to the effect of Jim Jasper's
warping reality and quite literally
bending the world around him the
Jasper's warp spreads throughout this
universe and with the realization that
it would spread into the multiverse
itself the dimensional development Court
destroys the earth 2:38 reality in its
entirety
number one the Days of Future past while
the crooked world was known for
establishing the concept of numerical
values to differentiate between
universes the data feature has
established the concept of alternate
universes in Marvel Comics designated at
Earth 8:11 this reality was originally
depicted as the future of the mainstream
Marvel Universe and came into existence
as a result of Charles Xavier Moore
McTaggart and Senator Robert Kelley all
being assassinated by mystique and her
Brotherhood of Evil Mutants responding
with the relaunch of the sintel program
but with the Sentinels becoming
self-aware and taking over the earth all
super-powered people mutant or otherwise
were either immediately executed or
placed in internment camps where they
were fitted with collars keeping them
from using their abilities using a
device to temporarily disrupt these
collars storm Wolverine Colossus Magneto
Kitty Pryde Franklin Richards and Rachel
summers make an escape using her vast
powers as a result of being the daughter
of Jean Grey and Scott Summers Rachel
summers sends the mind of Kitty Pryde
into a younger self arriving in time to
stop the assassination by mystique the
data-feature past became an alternate
reality with the mainstream Marvel
continuity continuing on without these
events having ever taken place with that
being said we're going to go ahead and
bring this video to an end I hope you
guys enjoyed it and let me know what
your choices are for your top 5 favorite
stories or realities and Marvel comics
without being said I will catch you guys
later peace